قال مراسل الجزيره ان وفدا من اكواس في
النيجر توجه الى القصر الرئاسي للقاء رئيس
المجلس العسكري وذلك بعد ساعات من اعلان
اكويس حسم قاده جيوشها موعده تدخلهم
العسكري المحتمل هناك وكان هناك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما فرص
نجاح وفد اكواسفنيا والى اي حد يمكن ان
يمثل اعلان مالي بوركينا فاسو استعدادهما
للدفاع عن النيجر وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان
تتطور مواقف روسيا والصين والولايات
المتحده وفرنسا من مجريات الاوضاع في
النيجر
هذا وفد تشكيلته تشيبي نوع من الامل الى
حد ما او فتح الخطيه الخيار الدبلوماسي من
جديد هي خطوات جديده تسابق الزمن للوقوف
امام
بديلا عن التدخل العسكري المحتمل والصعوبه
البالغه العسكري الذي اعلنت عنه امس
تواجهه عقبات كبيره
تحول
لانه في اتم الاستعداد للقاء وربما
التفاوض النقطه الثانيه انه كان لزاما على
عندما تتحدث دائما على ان الخيال العسكري
واخر خيار بعدما تستنفذ كل الطرق نحن نعلم
ان كل الطرق الدبلوماسيه لم كل الضغوط حتى
الان من اجل حل توافقي لا غالب ولا مغلوب
فيه لم تعد الدبلوماسيه في افريقيا اطلاقا
وللوفود الدبلوماسيه اي رئيس منقلب عليه
الحاله الوحيده التي حصلت حصلت عندنا في
موريتانيا 2009 من مصلحه
مغايره لهم لانهم في النهايه لديهم
يتمتعون بمرونه بمرونه
باستطاعتهم كذلك التفاوض خاصه حول مستقبل
الرئيس محمد بازوك او حول خريطه طريق
الانتقال الدبلوماسي لكن القبول التفاوض
لا يعني
بوركينا فاسو ومالي معنيه ثاني بشكل مباشر
بما يحدث ليس لي هذه الخطوه بالنسبه لي اي
دلاله ذا الطبيعه عسكريه خاصه خاصه ان
البلدين مالي تفقد السيطره على حواليه 50
الى 40 في 45 في المئه من اراضيها بسيطره
الجماعات المسلحه بوركينا تفقد حوالي
السيطره على حوالي 40% من عرضها لا يمكن
لي مالي بوركينا تحمي النيجر وهي لا تحمل
جزء من اراضيها يعني هذا الموضوع يؤدي في
الدول الرافضه لهذا المنحنى لهذا لهذه
المعالجه البحث الامنيه العسكريه في
التفكير في محاور جديده ما قامت به في
النهايه رغم انه رمزي بوركينا فاسو ومالي
هناك تسع دول 15 ابدت استعدادها لكن
الباقين بين بين الحياه وبين الرفض وهذا
فعلا يمكن يؤدي بهذه الدول ان تفكر مليا
لكن الدلاله رمزيه في التضامن
وفي دخول المنطقه في تحالف جديد يهدد حتى
سياسيا انسحاب منظمه الاكواس التي كانت في
الفتره الاخيره قبله لكثير من الدول
الافريقيه
على الحدود الجماعات المسلحه تسيطر وتقتل
في النيجر الجزء الشمالي من نيجيريا ايضا
يلتهم وفيه حرام اذا المنطقه ملتهبه جدا
واي تدخل عسكري سيزيد من
الانقسامات والمشاكل الامنيه الكبيره
والموجوده اصلا
اذا لاحظت معي كل تقريبا المقابله رئيس
الوزراء المعين لنيويورك تايم اهتمام
لان تكون في النهايه النيجر قاعده جديده
منصه
وهذا الامر مهم جدا بالنسبه المتحده
الامريكيه الراجح ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
لديها خيوط وعلاقات واتصالات بالمجموعه
الانقلابيه بالنيجر مؤشرات ذلك واضحه
تنتظر من موقف اكثر قوه من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وهو عدم التخاطب وعدم
التفاوض الا من خلال الاكواز مع السلطات
الجديده في النيجر الولايات المتحده لم
تمتزم بذلك توقعوا ان يكون في فعلا هناك
حل دبلوماسي لتمكين جديد من الانقلابيين
او تنظيم انتخابات لا يحضر بها قاده قدره
الانقلابين على اعطاء ضمانات الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وقدرتهم كذلك على
الحفاظ
اعتقد ستكون هي في النهايه مفتاح الحل
بالنسبه للنيجر